المساعدات السعوديه هي اول مساعدات دوليه
تدخل الى سوريا منذ ان وقع الزلزال قبل
سته ايام اذا هذه المساعدات كما تحدث هي
المساعدات السعوديه
والدوليه الاولى التي تدخل الى سوريا عبر
منطقه باب الحمام وبعد اقل من ساعاته الان
كنا نود ان نكون معكم بصوت وصوره ولكن
بسبب سوء شبكه الاتصال انا اشاهد الان
الشاحنات تعبر من المنفذ التركي باب غصن
او غصن زيتون الى منفذ باب الحمام وهي
المنطقه السوريه تنعبر معها الى الجانب
السوري
لنطلع على على هذه المساعدات وايضا كيفيه
ايصالها
والمستفيدين منها بالاضافه الى ذلك هذه
المساعدات لن تكون الاخيره بحسب تصريحات
مسؤوليه مركز الملك سلمان ومسؤوليه
المساعدات السعوديه بشكل عام التي تم
تسييرها بشكل عاجل الى سوريا وتركيا على
حد سواء هذه المساعدات التي تدخل الى
سوريا هي الاولى من نوعها على المستوى
التونسي ستكون بحجم ضخم كما اشاهد احد عشر
شاحنه محمله بكافه المساعدات الغذائيه
والدوائيه
وايضا الملابس الشتويه
والادوات التي يتم الاستفاده منها للدفع
بهذا الجو البارد جدا للمساعده المتضررين
السوريين على مواجهه الاضرار التي نجمت
جراء هذا الزلزال نايف